in time you will know what it's like to
lose read it
run from it in is near
we got one advantage
we have a dance once
so that's what we use
I think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good Wow today we've done science
for wonder this
we fetch for all of them
put that thing away now I don't want to
tell you again
[Music]
hi Regal Cinema fans I am Joe Russo and
I'm Anthony Russo and we are the
directors of Marvel Studios Avengers
infinity war the whole movie was shot
using IMAX cameras which means you're
gonna be able to see up to 26 percent
more image only in IMAX so please see
the movie the way it was meant to be
seen the way that we shot the film and
go out and get your IMAX tickets now
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so we could
fight the battles that they never could
the end is near
read it run from it
destiny still arise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Avengers
and is near
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you